guys were here and then then film of
comic-con today tell me who you are I am
Robb Stark bran stark Arya Stark Syrio
Forel would you like to see Syria make a
return on the show how would you like
that to be there is a rumor going around
that he's a faceless man so it could be
hiding in plain sight I think I'd really
like that she trusted him a lot so let's
hope so now Brown we've seen a lot of
walking from you this season haven't we
we've also seen Hodor doing some walking
with brown controlling his mind what did
you make of that I thought that was
pretty cool I did think that was cool
but yeah it's just a really interesting
plot device to sort of keep things going
and bran is definitely a contender for
the Iron Throne definitely and what are
you looking forward to in season 4 what
would you like to see happen I'd like to
see Geoffrey dying I think everyone
supposed to see Joffrey died
so I hope that happens oh I don't know
if it does enough but that's not looking
forward to yeah Joffrey dying and also
ayahs story but getting a lot more
interesting as the books go on some
looking forward to that in an ideal
let's bump up Joffrey scenario how would
you like to see it happen I oh I don't
know I'd quite like Aria to be the one
maybe or Santa maybe he wasn't very nice
to her i'm looking forward to Lady
Stoneheart actually and seeing if she
maybe she can pump to Joffrey off that'd
be awesome